all right this is rocket skates take two  this one's gonna be a little more  powerful than the last one so why these  are different bottle rockets  thank God I wonder where today  this is your game Nicholas if we're and  welcome to it I'm here to let you in on  a few ground rules you receive the very  first key and others will come  you'll never know where you'll find them  or how you'll need to use them so keep  your eyes open  how do you you can see me let's say the  question  activate death heads  yes activated  good job meatlug here you go darlin  mine's worth 10 yeah the black sheep  except for me we're attached genius quit  trying to tell me oh all my glory  it's my glory oh we're winning  everything  no sheep no whoa  he's a deep focus out there Bob this  obviously means a lot to him he shoots  it's going going  looks like coop has made a dream come  true for a very brave little Wow